- All right, we are here at the Oscars.
- Yes.
(audience cheering)
(audience applauding)
- That's right, where movie
lovers unite and watch TV.
- [Amy] Mm.
(audience chuckling)
This year, the Academy
hired three women to host
because it's cheaper than hiring one man.
(audience laughing)
It's fun, right?
- Yeah, you're right,
you're right, you're right.
But I'm still excited to be hosting,
representing Black women
who are standing proud.
- Yes, and I'm, and living out loud, yes.
- Yes.
And I am representing
unbearable white women
who call the cops when you
get a little too loud, okay.
(audience laughing)
- You know, we've been dealing
with COVID for two years.
It's been really hard on people.
- Yeah, I mean, just look
at Timothee Chalamet.
(audience chuckling)
- Oh God.
- Right.
(audience laughing)
- What happened?
- I don't know.
It's not good, it's not good.
- You know what, I'd still smash.
- You'd smash, okay.
(audience laughing)
- Wow, wow.
- Yeah.
- As many of you know, a
decision was made to present
some behind the scene
awards in the first hour.
- Yeah, it was a controversial
and difficult decision,
but, you know, I think we've moved on.
- I agree.
- Yes.
(electricity buzzing)
Yep.
- Uh-oh.
- Okay.
- Wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
- Look, we're all union.
- Yeah, we love (indistinct).
- Come on, that's not our decision.
- You know, there was a
lot of snubs this year.
- Mm.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, Rachel Zegler
for "West Side Story."
(audience applauding)
Yeah, Jennifer Hudson for "Respect."
- Yep.
- And Lady Gaga and Jared Leto
for house of random accents.
- Yes.
(audience laughing)
Yes.
- It's true.
It's true.
Yeah, you're right.
- This is kind of sad,
you know what's in the in
memoriam package this year?
- What's that?
- The Golden Globes.
- Mm.
- Ah.
(audience laughing)
- They didn't have any Black people.
They didn't have any Black members.
- No, they had to go.
- So they had to go.
- You know, I was very disappointed
that "Space Jam 2" did not get nominated
in the special effects
category for that hairline
they gave LeBron James.
- Oh my God, amazing.
- It was really good.
It was really good.
- Mm-hm.
- Boy, Black Twitter
is gonna love that one.
- I think so.
(Amy laughing)
- Yeah, what is that?
- No.
- You don't.
- No, no.
(audience laughing)
- Don't?
- It's not for you.
- Okay.
- I'll stay away.
- You know, this year we
saw a frightening display
of how toxic masculinity
turns into cruelty
towards women and children.
- I'll tell ya, damn that Mitch McConnell.
- I know, I know.
(audience laughing)
But, you know, I was
actually talking about
"The Power of the Dog."
- Oh, yes.
(audience applauding)
You know, I watched
that movie three times,
and I'm halfway through it.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
(audience laughing)
- [Amy] You're at the best part.
It's the best.
- Yeah, no, no, no.
Yeah, yeah.
One more week and you're in there.
- Stay with it?
- Stay with it.
- Yeah, stay with it.
- Yes.
- You know, Samuel L. Jackson is here.
(audience applauding)
Yes, there he is.
He just got the Governors Award
for his lifetime body of work.
(audience applauding)
Yes.
Woo.
(audience applauding)
- Eh.
(audience laughing)
- Did you just "eh" Samuel L. Jackson?
- I mean, I, I, I love
him, you know, he's my guy,
but I'm gonna be honest, there's
a few holes in his resume.
- Yeah?
(audience laughing)
No, for real, like where's
the Sam Jackson Rom-Com?
(audience chuckling)
Like where's you know Sam
Jackson and Jennifer Lewis
in "When this MoFo Met that MoFo?"
(audience laughing)
You know, or the sequel,
"Bitch, I said I love you!"
(audience laughing)
- No, you know what?
- He likes it, he likes it.
- You're right, and where is his musical?
Rent, "Ho, I Said Where's My Rent?"
- There ya go.
- Oh.
- I'd stream that.
- Yeah.
- I'd stream it.
- No, it's good.
- Well, we're gonna have
a great night tonight.
And for you people in Florida,
we're gonna have a gay night.
- [All Three] Gay, gay, gay,
gay, gay, gay, gay, gay, gay.
(audience cheering)
- We're your Oscar hosts.
I'm Wanda Sykes.
- I'm Amy Schumer.
- And I'm single.
- Oh boy.
- Okay, Regina.
(audience laughing)
I mean, it's not the time for that.
And providing the soundtrack
for the next hour,
give it up for the incomparable D-Nice!
(audience cheering)
- [Wanda] Welcome everybody to the Oscars!